[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
شي واحد صار اليوم يمكن من يوم قالوا لي
بتتكلم في الجماعه والشباب مشكورين الدعوه
كان وحده من الاشياء اللي صارت بالنسبه لي
وش الموضوع اللي بتكلم فيه طبعا وكانك راح
تتكلم واخر واحد وقدامك سبعه ثمانيه يمكن
70% اللي كنت اقوله قالوا يا شباب
يعني اقل يمكن احاول قدر الامكان الموضوع
يكون قريب وكان واحد والاسئله الحضور
مع الامطار طبعا الحين كلش تغير فنقول بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم
النقطه الرئيسيه اللي كنت ابغى اتكلم
عليها اليوم
النقطه اللي حاول اتكلم فيها وقدر الامكان
بحيث تكون فيها تواصل مباشر مع الحضور
الموجودين
النقطه الاولى في بالنسبه للحواجز عندنا
في الحياه تغير وتنقسم الاشياء كثيره بس
انا بتكلم على الشخصيه
والحاجز الاكبر اللي دائما نلقاه حواجز
داخليه عندنا تلقى عندك حاجز خوف حاجز عدم
المعرفه
طبعا كثير منها لها عوامل مختلفه نواجهها
من خلال المجتمع والامور اللي احنا نمر
فيها بشكل عام لكن الحاجز الاهم لليوم
عندي ويمكن يهمني من يوم حنا نبدا من ايام
المدرسه هو حاجه الشخصي داخلنا تلقى
الواحد يبغى يسال في الصف في البدايه من
واحنا صغار تخاف ترفع يدك لا احد يسالك
اذا وجهلك المدرس اصبعه بالسؤال البعض
يتحرج من هذا الموضوع طبعا ما نحس فيها
وحنا صغار ولا نعتقد انها غير مهمه ولكن
مع الزمن هذا الموضوع مهم لسبب واحد رئيسي
انه يبدا يصير عندك جرعه الجراه هذه يمكن
انت في المدرسه ما تحس فيها في الجام عه
يمكن ما تحس فيها بس في وقت العمل يختلف
الوضع تماما
في حياتك العلميه انت جالس في جهه يوم
تبدا تشتغل تجلس في الجهه الاخرى
فالاشياء اللي في بعض الاسئله اللي خلنا
نقول كانت معاك في ايامك ما تستخدمها راح
تستخدمها في الوقت اللاحق وهذه الجراه
اللي راح تفيدك كثير من الناس اليوم
يفتقدون لهذا الجانب فتلقى تضيع عليه فرص
عمل او في بعض الاحيان حتى ما يستطيع انه
يقدم بشكل كبير ولا يجري على اخذ مخاطره
لان الجراه مفقوده بالنسبه له طبعا الجراه
ليست مو بشرط تكون في التجاره الجراه ممكن
تكون في الوظيفه اللي انت موجود فيها في
دراستك اللي انت موجود فيها هذه كلها
اشياء تبنيها مع الوقت
في بعض الناس عندها رهبه من الكلام امام
العام انا بعض الحين تجيني الرهبات هذه بس
نحاول نتغلب عليها اول دقيقتين ثالث دقيقه
تلقى نفسك خلاص دخلت فورمه في الموضوع هذا
فهذه كلها ضمن عامل الجراه وهذا جانب مهم
جدا الواحد يتغلب عليه السلف ستيم ان انت
عندك اصلا داخليا تشجع نفسك على اداء
الشيء اذا انت ما تشجع نفسك لا تتوقع ان
التشجيع هذا راح يجيك من طرف خارجي وهذه
مشكله ثانيه اعتمادنا على طرف ثالث حتى
يدعمنا واعتمادنا على طرف ثالث بحيث انه
يعطينا الفكره وانه طبعا وهو جانب يمكن
اللي كنا اتكلموا فيه الاخوان في السابق
ان تجد الواحد لما يجي يبغى يتكلم مع احد
او يبغى يقدم على خطوه معينه يستشير طبعا
اوكي فهمنا ما خاب من الاستشار اول شيء
فهذه النقطه يهمني انا انك انت تروح
تستشير احد صحيح له خبره بالموضوع في
البعض لكن نبغى نستشير الناس القريبين منا
بحكم انه عندك الحيه ما تبغى احد يعرف انك
انت ناوي تقدم على خطوه معينه ويجي احد
ثاني طبعا يقول لك لا
اقضوا حوائجكم بالكتمان ترى في مبادئ بعض
الاحيان وان كانت صحيحه لكن لا هذه ما هي
ما تنطبق على كل الحالات تتغير من حاله
الاخرى فانك انت يعني للاسف انا من الناس
ترى الاعلن كل شيء في حياتي يعني الشيء
اللي تشوفونه قدامكم هو الشيء ما في شيء
موجود لو تقعد تحفر وراي ما راح تلقى شيء
ثاني كل شي قاعد اقوله وبعض الناس تتحرج
من النقطه هذه لكن الان السبب الرئيسي
اللي خليني اقولها انه لو شاركت احد ما
راح اخسر شيء
ويمكن اذكر واحده من الاشياء اللي اعتقد
قالها عبد الله سعيدان
انا ما في احد لها شيء عندك في الاخير
يعني اذكر اني شفت في اكثر من
طبعا كنت اتابع بعض المتحدثين السابقين
في نهايه المطاف مهما انتقدك الشخص لا راح
يزيدك شيء ولا راح ينقص من امرك شيء فهذي
نقطه مهمه
الحاجز المعرفي طبعا لما يجي يتكلم على
واحده من الاشياء اللي لاحظتها ان كل ما
الانسان تقدم في مرحلته العلميه كل ما بدا
يضيق نظره الحياه طبعا هذا غريب لان الشيء
الطبيعي ان الوعي المعرفي الزياده
المعرفيه والوعي العلمي اللي يكون عندك
والكتله الثقافيه اللي يتكون عندك مع
الوقت يفترض انها قاعده توسع لك المدارك
لكن تلقى بعض الناس لما يجي يدخل مثلا على
تخصص معين في الجامعه يبدا في تخصص هذا ما
نسبه التخصص يتحرج يغير ولكن والمشكله
الرئيسيه لانه يتخيل انه تخصص هذا كانه
رسمنا الطريق ومالك ترى الطريق هذا يمكن
فاخرج دار ما راح يغير عنه وهذا غير صحيح
واحده بالامثله اللي كنت اضربها دائما
كثير من الاصدقاء الدراسه الجامعيه في
نهايه المطاف لما تجي تدرس يفترض انك انت
يعني يعني افضل مثال انا ما اعرف يسمونه
اللي يحطونه على الحصان عشان يسكر في وقت
السباق يخلوني مركز على المسار اللي هو
موجود عليه يفترض ان الدراسه هذه قاعد في
البدايه في التخصص العام لو انظر لها
بنظره معرفيه المفروض اني انظر لها انك
قاعد تفتح لي المسار والافاق بحيث ان تكون
الافاق كلها مفتوحه قدامي الوعي المعرفي
اللي موجود عندي والحجم
الشهاده العلميه اللي انا قاعد اخذها انا
افترض انها اداه معرفه ما هي باداه قاعدت
تفلت لي الطريق وانا مضطر ما امشي اللي
على الاسفلت هذا لان في نهايه المطاف
الفكره منها انها تساعدك على تخطي
التحديات التي تواجهك في الحياه
في بعض الناس يعني بعطيكم مثال انا اتكلم
في نفسي اول ما تخرجت من الجامعه كانت
ويمكن كثير من الناس سمعوا جزء من الجانب
القصص هذه دخلت جدتي كانت تقول انك تحكي
كثير ويعني انك مزعج معنى صح واسئلتك
كثيره جدا كنت فضولي من وانا طفل
فقالت افضل مجال لك انك تروح محاماه دخلت
المحاماه
وبعد سنه يعني بعد اول سنه اثبت دراسه كان
عندي خمس مواد في السنه الاولى رسبت في
ثلاث نجحت في مادتين وسبت في ثلاثه طبعا
ما كانت المشكله في اني رسبت كانت المشكله
اني رسبت في اكثر مادتين كنت متوقع ان انا
ناجح فيهم ونجحت في المادتين اللي انا
متاكد 100% اني انا راسب فيهم يعبي لها
مبالغه واحد من المادتين هذه انا كاتب في
الدفتر الاجابه كاتب اني انا طالب اجنبي
ماني مقيم في الدوله هذه ما اعرف ايش
تقاليدكم والله هذه كانت ردي كيف نجحني ما
اعرف بس عموما هذا اللي حصل يوم رجعت يعني
جلسوا قالوا لي قلت اغير بلد ما ينفع معي
الجامعه هذي بغير تخصص
فكان الاستفسار طب ليش تبغى تغير قلت لاني
ما يعني اذا بجلس بالطريقه هذه اقعد انجح
في الشيء اللي انا متوقع اني راسب فيه
وارسف اللي انا ما اعرف متى مخلص يعني
ورجعت وقلت ابغى طب وكان يعني
الله يطول في عمرها الوالده تقول لا ما
راح تدخل طب لانك بتضيع وقتك في الدراسه
وكفايه انه علي سنه بعد الثانويه ما دخلت
في الجامعه وبعدين بديت في
القانون بعدين تركت القانون رحت هندسه
طبعا الهندسه قسم يمكن معروفه اللي تابعوا
بعض القصص دخلت اتصالات الكترونيات لاني
ما اعرف ارسم طبعا انا ما اعرف ارسم
الابتدائي
صدقا يعني هذه كانت المعاناه بالنسبه لي
يعني حتى انك تلون كان ما ادري وضعي سيء
كان جدا في الموضوع هذا
الهندسه استفدت منها من اول سنه في شيء
واحد رئيسي انها كانت تعطيني
سكول طريقه التفكير
عندك كيف تاخذ القرار نظرتك للامور ومن
اول يوم طبعا لا في مخي اني انا بروح في
جانب هندسي تقني ولا طبعا حاط في بالي انه
في الاخير بترجع السعوديه طيب احنا ما
عندنا ما عندنا ما عندنا شركات اللي بشتغل
فيها مصانع التقنيه فحدك في الاخير تشتغل
مبيعات يعني وفي نفس الوقت كنت اقرا واشوف
السي اوز حق الشركه طبعا طموح من اول يوم
ان يكون سيوه يعني في الموضوع
فلقيت انه ما في شخص فني وصل لهالمرحله
هذه كلهم كانوا جايين من باك جراند مبيعات
وتسويق واضح انه في الاخير بتبلف الناس
تسولف عليهم وتبيع وتطلع للمنصب اللي
تبغاه فالشاهدنا الكلام
ان التغيير هذا ما سبب لحرج لكنني كنت
مضغوط نفسيا لازم اخلص بسرعه عشان اروح
ارجع واقدر اشتغل بسرعه
لكن هذا الحاجز ما مثل لمساله التغيير ما
مساله حاجز عندي مو عشان اقول لكم اني كنت
شجاع بس انه جانب منها يمكن برغم انه في
ناس كثير قالوا تاخر وكنت اشوف اقراني
الان يعني انا لسه في سنه اولى جامعه الي
تخرج معي من الثانويه زملائي كانوا في سنه
ثالثه باقي لهم سنتين
عزلت نفسي فتره معينه اذكر يمكن ست شهور
ما كنت تتكلم مع احد طبعا كان في نفس
الوقت يمثل لي تحدي كبير انه كيف راح اسوي
كاتشب مع الناس بعدين ادركت قلت طيب في
عندي زملاء كانوا معي في الابتدائي وراحت
عليهم سنه سنتين فيعني في الاخير الوقت ما
هو بمانع لك انك انت تقعد تفكر وبرجع لهذا
الموضوع في سلايد لاحق
طبعا
هذا يمكن الشيء الاكبر حنا بعد ما نخلص
دراسه ونروح الجامعه طبعا وانت في اخر
سنين جامعه وبعض الناس الان يمكن صار في
تقدم الجيل الحالي افضل ان من السنه
الثانيه والسنه الثالثه يقعد يفكر في
الوظيفه في التدريب وين يروح
طبعا هذا كله ليش لانك تبغى تامن حياتك
ماليا واعتقادا ان التامين المالي ما راح
يجي الا اليوم سواء كنت ابي اصير في
الوظيفه معينه ولا ببدا بزنس معين المشكله
الموجوده هنا انك تبدا تضحي بالخطط طويله
المدى على بسبب لاجل خطط قصيره المدى وش
قصير المدى اول ما جاء اتوظف طيب كم
الراتب
وهو المدخل اي بس انا ابغى اكون مديري
رئيس الشركه وانت لسه توك يعني ايا كان
الكيان او ان ابغى كيان له سمعه ترى في
الاخير انت ما انت رايح تدخل تشتري لك
براند معين انا ابغى خبره معينه هذا الهدف
فيفترض ان اتعدى حاجز ان المساله انا لازم
اكون موظف في ارام طبعا على جيل لانه كان
ارامكو يعني
كان يعتبر حلم على فكره واحنا في
الابتدائي انا كنت في الخبر يعني كنت تشوف
الموظف سكرتي ارامكو عنده لاندكروزر في
اكس ار وبيت يعني هذا خلاص ختم اليوم من
يوم دخل سكرتي فبالنسبه لنا طبعا موضوع
مختلف
وهذا السبب اللي خليني اقول لك اليوم ان
مجرد ما تيجي تدخل تقول ابغى اكون في
وظيفه معينه لابد يكون عندك هدف على الاقل
انك وش الاشياء اللي بتعلمها من هذه
الوظيفه لانه هذه الوظيفه ما هي الوظيفه
اللي راح تتقاعد فيها ولا هي الوظيفه اللي
راح توصلك لنهايه اليوم اللي موجود انت
فيه وهذا هدف رئيسي بالنسبه لك لان كثير
من الناس اللي قاعد يطيحون فيها اليوم
العجله في انهم يحاولون يوصلون لنتائج
سريعه جدا واحده من الاشياء ويوم تكلمت
كلمني احد الاخوان كان يقول لو تتكلم على
الموضوع اللي
يقول انه الشباب ناجح وذكي والجيل الموجود
الحالي لكنه قاعد يطيح تحت ضغط العجله
طبعا العجله اليوم جزء منها قاعد يجي من
السوشيال ميديا لانك يطلع لك واحد
السوشيال ميديا يقول لك شوف انا ايش سويت
والانفلونسر عندهم فلوس وصار كان الهدف
اهداف سطحيه انت ما تشوف الا اللي قاعد
تشوفها في الشاشه اللي ورا الشاشه انت ما
تشوفه
هذه النقطه تفرق معاك كثير اليوم اشياء
كثيره انت مثل ما انتم الطفل لما كان احد
يقول لك انت لا تاكل بيدك اليمين وسديت
تكبر معاك وتكبر معاك العاده هذه في الشغل
وفي الدراسه في اشياء كثيره احنا اخذناها
لكن ما بدات تصير لها تفعيل الا يوم بدينا
نشتغل مثال
اللي كان يصرف كثير وهو صغير ما اتوقع
العاده هذه اتغيرت كنت تصرف كثير وانت
صغير تصرف كثير وانت كبير اللي كان متعود
انه اول ما يطلب شيء يحصله لمن يوصل
لمرحله العمل يبدا يواجه المشكله الكبيره
ليش مديرك في مكان العمل مو هو ابوك ولا
بامك ولا بواحد من عندك في البيت ما راح
يطبطبون عليك وهذه وحده المشاكل ان لما
نيجي الواحد يبدا يدخل ضحك تحت ضغط عمل
ويطلب اشياء وما يحصلها يطلب ادوات توفر
له ما يلقاها فجاه يتفاجا صار عليه ضغط
نفسي والحل اول ما يطلع من البيت للاسف
ولا احد يزعل مني كثير من اخوان والاخوات
في الجيل الجديد وبالذات يمكن
انا شفتها في كثير
من الفيميز النساء الان دخلوا على المجال
هذا جيد فيبدوا يحسون انهم مطالبين باداء
جهد مضاعف فتبدا تجتهد هي تحس نفسك قاعده
تحرق كثير في الشغل وما في تقدير يجي ذاك
طبع وش اسوي والله بستقيل يلا بروح البيت
طيب في وظيفه ثانيه لا ما في وظيفه
بالمناسبه انا طحت في المشكله هذه شخصيا
يعني لما صارلي خلاف وقررت اني اترك العمل
انا في حياتي كلها بالمناسبه ما اخذت الا
قرار عاطفي واحد ندمان عليه في حياتي الى
هذا اليوم
ان جيت في لحظه انفعال
حسيت اني انا مغدور فيني قلت ابى استقل
وبالفعل طلعت رحت كتبت استقاله من الحلال
طيب خلك معنا شهرين طبعا هم زعلوا مني
لاني ما سويت وانا استقلت لان صار في خلاف
بدون الدخول في تفاصيل لكن الخطا اللي انا
سويته استقلت ما عندي بديل متزوج وعندي
طفلين وقلت لهم يلا سلام عليكم يا جماعه
الخير
طبعا نتيجه لهذا الخطا راحت عليه مستحقات
راحت عليه امور كثيره لاني اخذت قرار تحت
انفعال من يومها اخذت قرار واحد في حياتي
اني لو انا معصب ما راح اخذ اي قرار لين
اطلع اهدى ثاني يوم ثالث يوم ابدا اتكلم
في الموضوع اللي كان مزعلني طبعا هذا
الشيء يمكن نرجع برضو وحده من الاشياء
اللي كان يقول عليها سيطره العقل عليك
طبعا للاسف انه صرت عقلاني زياده عن
اللزوم اني بديت افقد جانب لان العاطفه
شيء ضروري في حياتنا
للاسف يعني صاروا حتى اولادي يعانوا من
الموضوع هذا لان صرت اتعامل مع الكل بمنطق
بنسبه 100% وهذا صار بالنسبه لي سبب لي
معاناه نوعا ما حاول اسوي اللايف بالانس
هذه
طبعا هذه المعادله الى يوم ما وصلت ما
وصلت لها ولا اعتقد راح اوصل لها لان عندي
قناعه كبيره اذا انت تبغى تصير غير يعني
نجاحك مختلف ومتميز بشكل كبير جدا في
ضحايا كثير راح يمرون عليك في حياتك ولا
ميزه ولا بشيء الواحد يفتخر فيه لكن لابد
تعرف اي شيء تبغاه لابد راح تضحي بشيء
عشان تاخذ فيه لابد انه يكون عندك شيء راح
تضحي فيه عشان توصل للهدف اللي تبغاه اذا
عندك استعداد قد يكون التضحيه هذه في
اصدقاء قد تكون بحياه اجتماعيه قد يكون في
وقت انت قاعد تقضي لنفسك لكن
يعتمد انت وش
بالنسبه لك وش الشيء اللي تحس ان هذا
اعطاك الاكتفاء او الشيء اللي انت قاعد
تبحث عنه في البعض يبحث عن نجاح في بعض
يبحث عن مال في بعض يبحث عن وجهه اجتماعيه
انا والله اشتغل في مكتب الوزير الفلاني
طبعا في الاخير تشتغل في مكتب الوزير
طبعا
الحاجز الاكبر السوشل بارير والكارير وهذا
الشيء يعني يمكن لو بقول تيكوي رئيسي
تاخذونه من كل شيء بقوله اليوم يمكن موجود
هنا
الحاجز حاجز حاجز الثقافي وحاجز اجتماعي
وحاجز العادات والتقاليد انا طلعت من
السعوديه عام 2013 في عام 2015 كنت في دبي
وقابلت واحد من الاصدقاء اعتبر هذا صديق
متحفظ في حياته
وجالسين انا واياه في دبي وقاعد طلع جواب
طبعا وقتها كريم في السعوديه مطالع ما كان
فيه
وطالع اقول له ايش قاعد تسوي قال لي بس في
كريم بيجي بياخذ زوجته طبعا بالنسبه لي
هذه كانت صاعقه يعني انه مخلي زوجته
بيجيها واحد ياخذها من عند باب البيت
وتطلع معاه وبديت بعدها طبعا تشوف التغيير
والشفت اللي قاعد يصير في عقليه الناس
هذا بالنسبه لي كان يعتبر نوع من انواع
كسر الحواجز طبعا نجي بالنسبه للناس لما
تيجي تشتغل فيه كثير يقول لك انا في بعض
الناس ترى السد فاكشن حقهم انه عطني
المسمى الفلاني انا ما ابغى احس نفسي اني
انا اسمي شيء صغير ترى ما العلاقه يعني
التقاليد خلتنا انك انت لازم يكون عندك
برستيج معين عندك تتصرف بطريقه معينه تمشي
بطريقه معينه تاكل بطريقه معينه اي بس ترى
هذه كلها في الاخير شكليات ان تعيش 365
يوم في السنه كم يوم من هالثلاثه في السنه
هذه انت عايشها بين الناس اللي قاعد تحاول
انك تعطيهم انطباع غير حقيقي عنك
انا اليوم اجلس كثير من بعض الناس يقول لك
يا اخي قاعد تتكلم بطريقه غير انك يعني
يعتقدون انك قاعده تصنع ان كيف انه والله
انا في الاخير بسيط انا بسيط لاني ترى
طلعت من حياه بسيطه انا عشت في شقه مع
اهلي يعني ما كان عندي احمد الله سبحانه
وتعالى انه ما كان عندي هذا من اول يوم
ولا كان عندي اهتمام في نظره الناس يعني
اللي طالعني اليوم اقول والله ترضى فيني
مثل ما انا اهلا وسهلا فيني سلام عليكم ما
راح تغير من نفسي عشانك رحت غيرت نفسك
اليوم لبست وجوه الناس طالعوا فيك لانك
والله صرت في المكان الفلانيه او عندك
الثروه الفلانيه او عندك الحصيله العلميه
الفلانيه ترى بعد فتره تنتهي هذه كلها
وتبقى انتو نفسك
ومن يحبك راح يحبك لك مساله التقاليد اللي
احد يقول في بعض الناس الان يجي يتحرج
يقول لا بنتي ما يصير تروح المكان الفلاني
او زوجتي ما يحتاج تروح المكان الفلاني او
بالشكل الفلاني او ما تسافر لحالها مثلا
يختلف طبعا ما ابغى بكره احد يقول انا
قاعد اثور على اعدائك كل واحد وتقاليد منه
لكن اتكلم بشكل عام
انت اليوم قاعد في زمن
مختلف ومتغير وبشكل متسارع السوشيال ميديا
كسرت حاجز كبير جدا لانه اول انت ما تعرف
الا الشيء اللي انت متعرض له لكن اليوم
صار عندك انكشاف على ثقافات كثيره على
اديان كثيره على ناس جايه من اماكن كثيره
على لغات مختلفه
دخولك في مكان العمل اذا ما تدرك انك انت
داخل اتعامل مع البريطاني بطريقته واتعامل
مع الاسترالي بطريقته طبعا
اذا ما قدرت تكسر هذه الاشياء قد تواجه مش
صعوبات كبيره في اماكن العمل وبعطيكم مثال
على هذا الموضوع
قبل لما جيت اول مرحله امريكا من هنا تجي
ترسل للناس طبعا يعتبر عالم مختلف تماما
يعني وحده من الاشياء اللي صارت يمكن
استطرد عليها بشكل سريع في عام اعتقد 2014
كنت كان في ايفنت ورحنا انا واثنين من
الشباب السعوديين وكان الواحد المتحدثين
المؤسس شركه مؤسس في انستجرام الرجال في
ذاك اليوم اللي حنا قاعدين نشوفه فيه
ثروته ما تقل عن اثنين مليار دولار طالع
باك باك ويركب تاكسي ويروح وقعدنا لحقنا
اوراك يبغى يصور ويصور الرجال
غريب الحين هذا كل المليارات طبعا هو
متوقع الحين احنا عندنا لو واحد عنده عشره
مليون في ثلاثه قاعدين يمشون وراها شايل
الشنطه
واذا اثنين مليار وباك باك وماشي واحد
يدري عنه
قلت لهم ثقافتهم مختلفه هم بالنسبه لهم
ينظرون التغيير على مستوى العالم وبعد
التغيير على شكله وايش قاعد يصير معه
فعوده على
بالنسبه اول ما رحت امريكا وقاعد
اصطدمت في الثقافه لان طالع من هنا تكتب
مثلا اجي اقول صلاح ارجو برسل له ايميل
اقول دير صلاح عارف انت تسولف زي اللي كيف
حالك شو اخبارك امورك طيبه وتحت في الاخير
كل انواع السلامات والتحيات وهو سطرين
الزبده اللي انت تبغاها
الحين انا مرسل الرساله هذه المحامي انا
اللي ادفع له فلوس يعني هو انا عميل مو
العكس رد علي نبيل وسطرين كذا زي اللي
شافني وهو ماشي
صراحه في البدايه يعني حسيت اني تهزات
يعني ليش عاملني بطريقه هذه لين بديت
استوعب بالموضوع هذا ان الجماعه هذيلي كل
الدقيقه بالنسبه لهم الثانيه لها معنى لا
تحط لي حرف انا ما احتاجه في الايميل
الين استرجعت الموضوع هذا من اول وجديد
عارف اللي يبدا يقول لك تعيد التوصيلات في
مخك طبعا الحين عندي مشكله انا رجعت هنا
الحين مره ثانيه مع الناس ترسل لواحد ما
تقول له والله مساك الله بالخير تدخل على
طول كذا حتى ما في سلام عليكم والله
الشغله الفلانيه عندكم كذا يحس كان يقول
لك انت قاعد يعني تتامر علي فاختلاف
الثقافات اذا ما تعرف ثقافه في كل مكان
اولا حمايه لنفسك عشان لا تاثر فيها ثانيا
حتى فعلا يصير عندك اداب مع المجتمع
الثاني الموجود هذا طبعا في مجتمعات مثل
اللي حنا موجودين فيها فيها كثير من غير
السعوديين ومع انفتاح البلد ودخول
المستثمرين الاجانب بتجيك شركات اجنبيه
كثيره المفروض انه في فرص عندكم كثيره
فاذا ما راح اتكلم مع كل واحد باللغه اللي
هو يفهمها قد افقد كثير من الفرص
طبعا نيجينال
نجلس اليوم مع كل احد عندي
الحاجز العاطفي في التعامل
طبعا عده عوامل ان بعض الاحيان اللي كنت
اللي ارجع هذه النقطه اللي قلتها برجع
عليها اول الضغوط اللي تواجهنا في مجال
العمل احد يجي يبغى يدخل في وظيفه معينه
يبدا يجي عليه ضغوط يجيه يعني انا سمعت
اسمع كلمه هذه بشكل كبير جدا واحد من
الاخوان قابلني برا دكتور يقول عنده شركه
في مجال منتل هلف
انا من يوم جت كورونا اتوقع يمكن مر علينا
فوق 20 شركه كل مشكلتهم اللي يعالجونها ما
انت الناس يوم قعدت مع نفسها تحول الى
نفسيات شوف لما نقول وعلى واحد نفسيه هذا
نتكلم عليها طيب
ويمكن كثير من اللي في السوشيال ميديا
بالذات
قبل شوي الدكتوره ساره كانت تقول والله
جاها هجوم كبير جدا في السوشيال ميديا
طبعا
فين انا اشوف نوع نوعين من الناس
والسوشيال ميديا في ناس اللي يحس انه لازم
يرد على كل واحد قاعد يكلمه وكل واحد قاعد
يقول فيه كلام وفي ناس شاري راسها ومع لها
ماشيه في حياتها
ما هو مساله انه يخلق لك تلد ولكن كثر ما
انها مساله انك انت لما تجلس احد ينتقدك
انا عارف انه ما هو لا هو يعرفني ولا انا
اعرف العلاقه اللي موجوده بيننا اذا كانت
في تويتر هي علاقه الميه واربعين حرف اللي
مكتوبه هنا كثر الله خيرها ممكن يحط رد
عني يقعد يتكلم من الصبح لليل بس مره
ثانيه انت في عالم متغير وسريع مساله انه
يجيك هذه جزء كبير منها الهشاشه اللي
قاعده او الضعف النفسي اللي قاعد يصير لان
من الصغر للاسف احنا قاعدين نحاول نربي
جيل نعطيه كل شيء يبغاه
ونعتقد انه لما نوفر الامور بسهوله تبدا
يعني
تصير جراند يعتقد ان هذا حق ومو صحيح ان
هذا الشيء حق
يعني وهذه وهذا شيء يمكن انا احاول اتبعه
في ابنائي طبعا لسبب واحد انا دائما وجزء
كبير من الظهور والمواضيع اللي اتكلم فيها
ترى لها سببين اول شيء دائما اسال نفسي في
كل كلمه اكتبها
هل
بكره اذا ربك خذ امانته تركت شيء مفيد
للناس ولا لا
والشيء الثاني بكره ترى بيجون عيالك وعيال
عيالك تبغى يعني مبدا اللي يسمونه
[موسيقى]
يعني انك انت قاعد تحاول على قولهم متسبك
تعطي شيء اعتقاد انه بيجي احد بعدك يؤدي
نفس العمل اللي انت قاعد تؤديه وتكتمل
الرساله هذه طبعا وانظر لها بمعزل مو بشرط
ان احد يسوي الهدف مو انك انت قاعد تعطي
لانك تنتظر تاخذ لكن على امل انه يطلع
بكره شخص ثاني يعطي ويستفيده مثل ما اليوم
قد اكون افدت بعض الافراد اتمنى بكره يجي
احد كذلك يفيد سواء كان افراد عائلتي او
ناس اعرفه
هذا كان الرسالتين الرئيسيات اللي موجوده
بالنسبه لي في موضوع
فيما يخص البارير
ابى اختم شغله رئيسيه لانه اذا بدخل في
البارير يمكن ممكن يقعد يتكلم عليكم هنا
اربع خمس ساعات ولا راح نخلص
لكن الهدف الرئيسي ويمكن هذا الشيء اللي
احاول دائما اوصلها بالذات
في اي خطاب للشباب والشابات السعوديين
احنا نتكلم على جيل يمكن كنا صغار ما كنا
نعرف عن الخطط الخمسيه كثير ما كنا نقرا
ما كان عندها اهتمام ما كان عندنا اطلاع
اطلاعنا كان على الشيء اللي قدامنا لانه
انت ذيك الاوقات ما عندك الا الاعلام
التقليدي وقنوات مباشره موجوده اليوم صار
عندك اشياء كثيره جدا في فرق صار يا جماعه
من بعد
رؤيه المملكه اللي اطلقها سمو الاله العهد
صار عندك خطه واضحه قدامك اليوم لعشر
سنوات قدام
صار في خط واضح انا ما اعرف كم واحد منكم
بس لو ترفعوا لي اياتكم اللي قرا الرؤيه
كامله بالتفصيل
يعني ما نوصل للموجودين عشره في المئه
واعتقد اقل
انا انصحكم ترجعون تقرون تقرون اوراق
الرؤيه بالتفصيل لسبب اللي قاعد يصير
اليوم في المملكه مثل واحد قاعد يرسم لوحه
اذا جيت جلست وراي فنان
يقعد يرسم وانت ما تعرف اللوحه هذه وشو
بتحس انك قاعده تشخبط على ورق الى ان
تكتمل الرسمه حنا ما زلنا الرسمه هذه ما
اكتملت
وكلكم في يدكم انكم تكونون
لكم يد في اكمال الرسمه هذه واخراجها بشكل
مناسب السؤال هل الطريق سهل لا هل الطريق
معبد انك انت تمشي فيه كذلك لا
لكن هل انتم عناصر في نهايه المطاف
مستفيدين من هذه الرؤيه والاثار بالنسبه
لها والصعوبات اللي بتمشي فيها نعم يفترض
ان احنا كلنا نشتغل حتى نصل بهذه الرؤيه
الافضل مكان في وجهه نظري الشخصيه
الرؤيه لو كانت لو تحقق منها خمسين ستين
في المئه فانت حققت نقله كبيره جدا وهذا
نقطه مهمه ما راح تصير الا باياديكم
برؤيتكم بدعمكم مساله ان احنا نجلس في بعض
الناس نسمع اصوات مخالفه واعلام مخالف
كل احد بيتكلم في نهايه المطاف يعني ما
يرمى الا شجره المثمر فطالما انك انت ماشي
وحتى لو احد جاء قال لك ترى الرسمه في
الاخير راح تطلع شيء نتاكد انك انت ممكن
تكون لك يد ان الرسمه هذه في النهايه تطلع
رسمه مناسبه لكن ما راح تصير بيدي لحالي
ولا بيدي بيدكم لحالكم هذه بتصير بالتعاون
الجميع بالتوفيق للجميع شكرا جزيلا لهذا
الدعوه